aufbruch und mahnung die korona zahlen
entwickeln sich positiv
aber vor den pfingstfeiertagen sagt das
robert koch institut die virus gefahr
ist noch nicht gebannt
eine waffenruhe und neue gewalt während
der konflikt im gaza-streifen fürs erste
beendet scheint gibt es in jerusalem
neue zusammenstöße und skandal um einen
legendären fernsehen moment die prinzen
william und harry machen ein
bbc-interview für den tod ihrer mutter
mit verantwortlich
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers hinein einen guten
abend und willkommen bei uns geben sie
uns 20 minuten für die welt an diesem
freitag den sport steuert nachher keiner
stresow bei ich grüße sie guten abend
wir beginnen heute mit der korona lage
in deutschland unmittelbar vor pfingsten
die bewegt sich gerade zwischen hoffnung
und vorsicht zwischen aufbruch und
geduld einerseits die inzidenz und die
zahl der neuinfektionen sinken seit
wochen stetig das weckt natürlich
wünsche dass noch mehr cafés und
biergärten auf machen das einkaufen
wieder normal läuft und mehr kontakte
erlaubt sind
der bundesgesundheitsminister sieht
erfolge bei der korona bekämpfung und
beim impfen aber er appelliert alle
sollten vorsichtig bleiben frank
buchwald aus berlin atmet auf nach
monaten des lotter uns öffnen vorsichtig
wieder ein paar restaurant terrassen
lang vermisste leichtigkeit im ersten
sonnenschein allzuviel lockerungen aber
könnte schaden warnt ergo-chef wieder
darum appellieren wir so intensiv daran
dass man schrittweise öffnet und diese
grundregeln einfach behält ich sehe auch
gerade das masken tragen als einen sehr
geringen eingriff in die innersten das
freiheitliche leben von uns einzeln
stichwort masken niedersachsen hatte
kurz über lockerungen nachgedacht
wissenschaftler des max planck instituts
erhalten gerade die medizinischen masken
für besonders wichtig
unter welchen bedingungen welche maske
jetzt vorgeschrieben ist das muss man
dann immer anpassen aktuell wäre es
einfach völlig verfrüht die nutzung von
masken aufzugeben noch besser mehr
impfungen auch hier kommt deutschland
voran wenn auch langsamer als andere
länder
der minister trotzdem optimistisch
wunder sind nicht zu erwarten wunder
können wir auch keine versprechen wir
können immer nur so viel für impfen wie
wir auch an impfstoff geliefert bekommen
und nur verhelfen was da ist aber ich
finde die entwicklung der letzten wochen
zeigt doch deutlich wie stark die an
dynamik haben gewinnen können
noch ist das virus also nicht besiegt
doch immerhin die hoffnung wächst auf
einen sommer wir vor corona war
zumindest ein bisschen
die aktuellen corona zahlen zeigen
weiter einen positiven trend bei den neu
gemeldeten ansteckungen laut
robert-koch-institut waren es 8769
innerhalb von 24 stunden und damit 2567
weniger als vergangenen freitag 226
todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben tage
incidents sinkt bundesweit auf 67,3 die
impfungen sollen jetzt auch in ärmeren
teilen dieser welt stärker an laufen
können als bisher
beim globalen gesundheitsgipfel der
g-20-staaten in rom wurde zugesagt dass
die impfstoffhersteller in diesem jahr
1,3 milliarden dosen zum
selbstkostenpreis an ärmere länder
liefern die europäische union spendet
zudem 100 millionen dosen aus ihrem
bayern tag vertrag an staaten in afrika
wer bei uns gegen korona geimpft ist
kann das bislang nur analog nachweisen
eben mit einem simplen aufkleber im
gelben impfpass das soll sich in den
kommenden wochen ändern wenn das
digitale eu zertifikat kommt mit dem
kann man dann corona impfungen
überstanden erkrankungen und negativer
tests nachweis per qr code auf dem
smartphone
so soll reisen in europa wieder leichter
möglich sein
dass so was kommen würde ist seit
monaten bekannt und trotzdem sieht es
jetzt so aus dass die digitalisierung
der daten in deutschland zum problem
wird es wenn regen dr mario gomez ist am
limit schon seit wochen sie und ihr team
in der hamburger hausarztpraxis impfen
im akkord die nachweis darüber gibt es
im gelben im sollten alle patienten
nachträglich auch noch einen digitalen
pass haben wollen wäre das schlicht zu
viel
sozusagen noch mal zusätzlich
verpflichtet werden sollen
verwaltungstechnische aufgaben zu
übernehmen die in kein zeitplan
hineinpassen würde man nur das ist ja
eben nur mal einen code auszuführen
das ist logistisch nur sie können dass
sich ausrechnen einfach irgendwo
überhaupt nicht zu machen
deshalb sollen auch die apotheken helfen
auch hier so der plan können bald
vollständig geimpfte personen ihren
digitalen nachweis abholen
technisch anders bereits in den
kommenden zwei drei wochen losgehen
sagte der bundesgesundheitsminister
heute mittag und lässt die laute kritik
der ärzte und apotheker an sich
abprallen
natürlich soll für ersten und erste wie
für die apothekerin apotheker der
zusätzliche aufwand vergütet werden dann
da auch mitzuhelfen und wenn 60.000
70.000 arztpraxen und 20.000 apotheken
gemeinsam das stemmen dann ist das auch
machbar
der imf nachweis ist ein qr-code der
überall in europa lesbar und prüfbar
sein wird schon heute müsste er für fast
elf millionen vollständig geimpften
deutsche nachträglich erstellt werden
manches im zentrum ist dafür vorbereitet
andere hingegen ersticken in solchen
aktenbergen die praxis software von
maria home es soll frühestens anfang
juli qr-code tauglich sein ihre
patienten werden sich also noch lange
mit dem gelben im heft ausweisen müssen
das erhält in jedem fall seine
gültigkeit das thema bleibt uns erhalten
dann gucken wir jetzt wieder das corona
management der politisch
verantwortlichen bei den deutschen an
kommt das neue zdf politbarometer hat
nachgefragt und matthias fornoff mit
welchem ergebnis die lage hat sich
leicht entspannt
und damit steigt auch die zufriedenheit
eine klare mehrheit von 60 prozent der
befragten findet die aktuell geltenden
maßnahmen
richtig deutlich mehr als vor zwei
wochen
knapp jeder vierte hält sie für
übertrieben und nur noch 14 prozent
finden sie müssten noch härter ausfallen
beim impfen hat sich das tempo deutlich
erhöht deshalb sagen mittlerweile 42
prozent das impfen läuft er gut so viele
wie noch nie eine mehrheit von 56
prozent aber findet das impfen läuft
nach wie vor eher schlecht und dann
kommen jetzt erst auf das große bild die
politische stimmung in deutschland und
zwar insbesondere mit blick auf die
partei die da im moment vorne liegt ja
und das sind die grünen sie bleiben
stärkste partei knapp vor der union
wir haben gefragt ob man den grünen denn
zutraut die bundesregierung zu führen
das bejahen immerhin 44 prozent eine
mehrheit von 54 prozent sagt aber nein
das trauen wir ihnen nicht zu
mehrheitlich sehen dass die anhänger
aller parteien so außer den anhängern
der linken wo es ein gemischtes bild
gibt und natürlich den anhängern der
grünen selbst die
grünen-spitzenkandidatin annalena
baerbock verliert deutlich an zustimmung
und liegt im direkten vergleich bei der
k-frage sowohl hinter armin laschet als
auch hinter olaf scholz auch an diesem
freitagabend ist wieder vielen dank sehr
gern und das komplette politbarometer
wie immer nachher im heute-journal und
schon jetzt finden sie in unserer app
und auf zdf heute alle ergebnisse etwa
auch welche politiker besonders beliebt
sind und wir bleiben noch einen moment
bei den grünen nach annalena baerbock
hat auch der frühere grünen-chef cem
özdemir den dem bundestag
sonderzahlungen aus seiner partei nach
gemeldet rund 20.000 euro von 2014 bis
alles sei ordentlich versteuert zuvor
hatte bereits annalena baerbock mehr als
25.000 euro nachgemeldet die sie als
bundesvorsitzende von ihrer partei
bekommen hat sie selbst kommentierte das
so
das war ein blödes versäumnis unser
nächstes thema heute abend der
gaza-konflikt da gilt seit heute nacht
eine waffenruhe zwischen israel und der
hamas von einem wirklichen frieden ist
die region allerdings weit entfernt
elf tage lang dauerten die jüngsten
gefechte die palästinensische seite
meldet 2 143 tote in gaza nach
israelischen luftschlägen
zehntausende haben ihre wohnungen
verloren in israel wurden zwölf menschen
getötet durch raketen der hamas axel
sturm
von hier aus sieht man ganz gaza wie
schön es wäre wenn es frieden gäbe
shirley gut stadt hat ihren mann und
ihre tochter wieder als die raketen der
hamas flogen sind ihre liebsten in den
norden gefahren nur weg von hier weg aus
dem dorf das direkt am gazastreifen
liegt jetzt sind sie wieder da aber
charlie selbst war nie weg
draußen waren die raketen und das
artilleriefeuer hier drinnen aber habe
ich mich sicher gefühlt
das ist mein platz hier ich bin es
einfach leid immer abzuhauen
die gut stadt sind all das gewohnt den
beschuss den raketen terror die
unsicherheit jetzt sind sie erleichtert
erleichtert sind sie auch im
gazastreifen aber nicht nur das der
raketen terror der hamas ist bei vielen
gut angekommen so wird das freude über
die waffenruhe auch eine jubel stunde
für die radikalislamische organisation
wir feiern weil wir die juden besiegt
haben wir danken unserer
verteidigungsarmee israels premier lässt
keinen zweifel daran wer seiner meinung
nach sieger ist in diesem konflikt der
elf tage gedauert und über 250
menschenleben gekostet hat wie ich
versprochen habe haben wir der hamas
stark geschadet weit mehr als ihre
anführer sich das vorgestellt haben
sie haben elf tage intensive schläge
eingesteckt und einen tiefen rückschlag
erlitten
angespannt war die stimmung an diesem
tag immerhin die waffen schwiegen
beim freitagsgebet in der
al-aksa-moschee allerdings gab es
ausschreitungen und weiter live nach tel
aviv guten abend axel sturm und jetzt
wie sehen die menschen in israel die
situation auch innenpolitisch ja viele
hier sehen israels premier benjamin
netanyahu politisch als sieger dieses
konfliktes wieder einmal konnte er sich
als sicherheitspolitiker profilieren als
starker mann der israel
so ist die grundannahme im moment und da
gibt es natürlich auch noch andere
stimmen obwohl zwei stunden vor ausbruch
des konfliktes ein breites
oppositionsbündnis gegen ihn geschmiedet
worden war von ganz rechts bis ganz
links mit arabischen stimmen all das ist
jetzt obsolet die krise hat netanyahu
zeit verschafft und die bemühungen der
opposition gegen vorerst auf eis als
lektoren zdf live tel aviv herzlichen
dank und damit nach deutschland und zu
einem fall in dem der richter heute von
einer tat spricht die fassungslos mache
im herbst vergangenen jahres sticht ein
syrer in dresden auf zwei männer ein
einer stirbt sein partner wird schwer
verletzt
das gericht urteilt heute lebenslang und
behält sich vor dass der täter
möglicherweise nie wieder aus dem
gefängnis entlassen wird christoph
schneider berichtet ohne jede regung
verfolgte abdul hadi knapp zweistündige
urteilsbegründung
obwohl der angeklagte zum tatzeitpunkt
erst 20 jahre alt war also
heranwachsender wurde er nach
erwachsenenstrafrecht zur höchststrafe
verurteilt grund das gericht ließ dem
ergebnis zu der erkenntnis gekommen dass
die bei dem angeklagten keine
reifeverzögerung vorliegt und dass auch
keine wesentlichen
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten mehr gegeben
sind sondern er in seiner auffassung
durchaus verfestigt war für das gericht
ist erwiesen dass abdullah hdmi essener
steht am abend des vierten oktober 2020
unvermittelt auf ein schwules paar aus
nrw das in dresden urlaub machte
eingestochen hatte der vorsitzende
richter deutlich
der angeklagte habe aus religiöser
verehrung gehandelt landeskriminalamt
und der sächsische verfassungsschutz
stuften den angeklagten nach einer
jugendhaft weiterhin als islamistischen
gefährder ein überwachten ihn auch
teilweise trotzdem geschah die tat
der vorsitzende richter stellte am ende
der sitzung die frage ob die tat hätte
verhindert werden können
durch eine fußfessel oder eine
dauerhafte überwachung
doch die zuständigen behörden gingen
davon aus dass der angeklagte nach der
entlassung aus der jugendstrafanstalt
erst einmal in seinem neuen leben in
freiheit ankommen will bevor er eine
gewalttat verübt
sollte der angeklagte einzeltäter seine
radikalislamistische gesinnung in der
bevorstehenden langen haft nicht ändern
wird er wohl nie wieder auf freien fuß
kommen
abdullah h kann gegen das urteil noch
rechtsmittel einlegen
jetzt zu einer umstrittenen praxis mit
der nach dem willen des bundestages zum
ende des jahres endgültig schluss ist
dem töten von küken kaum geschlüpft und
gleich geschreddert rund 45 millionen
männliche küken werden in deutschland im
letzten jahr getötet zu unwirtschaftlich
sind sie für die industrie weil sie
keine eier legen und weniger fleisch als
hennen liefern
doch jetzt sollen auch die männlichen
küken ein recht auf leben bekommen
mullen l hier im niedersächsischen
betrieb in uelzen werden die männlichen
küken mit aufgezogen die zusatz kosten
die entstehen sind auf die eier umgelegt
es sind die bruder hähne der legehennen
so nennt sich auch diese initiative
gegen das massenhafte küken töten wir
als bruder an initiative hat die brücke
vom hahn zum endkunden geschlagen der
endkunde zahlt 4 cent mehr für das geht
durch den handel bis zum hahn wirklich
direkt auf den landwirtschaftlichen
betrieb der diesen hahn aufzieht
initiativen die laut umfragen der
verbraucherzentrale gut ankommen 75
prozent der kunden sind bereit mehr für
sei zu zahlen wenn dafür das massenhafte
küken töten beendet wird
auch der zentralverband der
geflügelindustrie nennt den ausstieg
ethisch richtig warnt aber vor einem
nationalen alleingang und vor
wettbewerbsnachteilen der deutschen
geflügelwirtschaft das deutsche gesetz
kann nicht verhindern dass man zum
beispiel jung kennen und weibliche küken
aus frankreich oder holland importiert
deren männliche bürger dort weiter
getötet werden bunte und handel setzen
schon jetzt auf moderne technologien das
geschlecht des kükens immer zu erkennen
so werden männliche embryonen vor dem
schlüpfen aussortiert tierschützer
kritisieren diesen weg als falsch
plädieren für ein grundsätzlich anderes
system das viele geld das das
bundesministerium in die erforschung der
geschlechter kennung am reingesteckt hat
wäre besser investiert gewesen in die
praxisreife von zwei nutzung zählern
gemeint ist eine hühnerzucht die beides
kann hennen die eier legen und hähne die
gemästet werden
mit drastischen worten kritisiert das
britische königshaus die medien und
insbesondere praktiken des öffentlich
rechtlichen senders bbc
es geht um ein legendäres interview mit
prinzessin da jänner 1995 das damals 23
millionen menschen in großbritannien
geguckt haben eine untersuchung ergibt
jetzt dass der bbc-reporter damals
gefälschte dokumente eingesetzt hatte um
zugang zu der jänner zu bekommen und sie
dazu zu bringen über ihre ehe mit prinz
charles auszupacken
vor allem da jonas söhne sind wütend die
bbc hat sich entschuldigt steht aber
enorm unter druck aus london andreas
stamm
es gilt als das royale interview
prinzessin diana öffnet sich dem bbc
journalisten martin bashir spricht etwa
über ihre zerrüttete ehe nun in meiner
ehe waren wir zu dritt also etwas eng
das interview das das königshaus
erschüttert basiert auf lügen mit tricks
hatte der journalist sich das vertrauen
der janus erschlichen so ein
untersuchungsbericht 25 jahre später
baschir hatte unter anderem bankauszüge
gefälscht um dana von einem komplott des
königshauses zu überzeugen was dana sohn
prinz william ungewohnt deutlich
kommentiert fehler der bbc haben die
angst paranoia und isolation meiner
mutter verstärkt an die ich mich in den
letzten jahren mit ihr erinnere was mich
am traurigsten macht hätte die bbc die
vorwürfe aus dem jahr 95 ordentlich
untersucht hätte meine mutter wenigstens
gewusst dass man sie betrogen hatte
die bbc entschuldigt sich nun
journalistische standards seien verletzt
worden
doch vieles wirke aufgebauscht so
experten die konservative regierung
johnson liege im dauerclinch mit der bbc
wolle immer mehr einfluss auf deren
berichterstattung ausüben viele leute
argumentieren dass die bbc mittlerweile
ängstlich und sie nicht mehr unabhängig
von der regierung sei fehler dieser art
bestärken diejenigen die hinter der bbc
her sind
ein einzelfall 25 jahre her damals mit
gravierenden konsequenzen für eine
familie das königshaus er könnte nun
dazu führen dass der streit um die
zukunft der öffentlich rechtlichen bbc
weiter eskaliert und wir sind heute
abend erzählen dieser sendung beim sport
handball katja und zunächst geht's aufs
eis und so kann eine wm doch mal
losgehen die deutsche eishockey
nationalmannschaft ist mit einem neuen
zu 4 sieg in die titelkämpfe in riga
lettland gestartet
zugegebenermaßen gegen extrem
ersatzgeschwächt die italiener die im
vorfeld der wm gleich 15 positive kroner
fälle zu beklagen hatten
das junge deutsche team geht durch
diesen treffer von routinier tom
kühnhackl in führung dann aber
verblüffen die azzurri italien durch die
ausfälle mit einer art b- team am start
trifft innerhalb von 25 sekunden gleich
zweimal kurz vor der ersten pause kann
kapitän moritz müller ausgleichen
im zweiten drittel hagelt es
ausschließlich tore für das deutsche
team
schlag auf schlag steht es 7 zu 2
unschön das foul an marco rose mit
gerechtfertigter großer 5 minuten strafe
für jonas müller
aber selbst ein zeitweiliges 325
unterzahlspiel kann die deutschen nicht
irritieren
am ende gewinnt die mannschaft von
bundestrainer toni söder holm verdient 9
zu 4
morgen dann gegen norwegen zum fußball
das thema des morgigen letzten
bundesliga-spieltag ist und bleibt die
frage wer steigt wie schalke direkt ab
die kandidaten sind neben dem ersten fc
köln werder bremen und arminia bielefeld
noch 22 stunden bis zur entscheidung
die richtung klar bielefeld mit der
besten ausgangsposition im abstiegskampf
aus wenig haben sie viel gemacht ein
sieg fehlt noch zum klassenerhalt jetzt
geht es natürlich darum dieses
nasenspitzen dieses enge rennen des
racer haben natürlich auch genauso in
dieser konstellation auch zu ende zu
bringen
beim abstiegskonkurrenten bremen ist
trainer kurfeld geschichte zu oft
jubelten die gegner jetzt soll es der
erfahrene thomas schaaf richten
wir haben zu viel über uns ergehen
lassen und das müssen wir ändern wir
müssen dort eben auch etwas dominanter
auftreten jeder für sich und dann eben
zu einer guten teamleistung zu kommen
gehen oder bleiben das ist die frage die
entscheidung sie fällt morgen und alles
wichtige dazu natürlich im aktuellen
sportstudio
vielen dank hat ja hier gerne so wie
sieht das aus wenn nach langer
zwangspause
der fröhliche nervenkitzel zurück ist so
dieser vergnügungspark in rust in baden
württemberg hat wieder auf als einer der
ersten
es ist ein modellprojekt mit tests mit
masken und mit ziemlich begeisterten
probanden
geht alles nach plan dürfte es bald
wieder 10.000 besucher am tag sein
bergauf geht es auch beim wetter
jedenfalls was die temperaturen angeht
am pfingstmontag steigen sie bis 23 grad
mehr gleich von katja oliver ich
empfehle das heute schon mal mit der
kollegin marietta slomka um 22 uhr ab
morgen und über die pfingstfeiertage ist
petra gerster hier für sie da und freut
sich auf sie von uns allen im team danke
fürs zuschauen machen sie sich ein sehr
angenehmer abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
besondere an dieser wolken und regen
spirale von dem sturmtief marco ist das
zwischendurch auch mal ein bisschen
platz bleibt für klaren himmel morgen
dann auch für sonnenschein
es gibt regen der fällt mit dieser
kaltfront denn der nacht an den
alpenrand auch im nordwesten beginnt es
bereits wieder neu zu regnen bei einem
stürmischen wind aus südlichen
richtungen die temperaturen sinken in
dieser nacht auf 10 bis 5 grad und
morgen gibt es dann werte von immerhin
15 bis 19 grad in einem streifen von der
ostsee bis zum oberrhein in den
mittelgebirgen und am alpenrand bleibt
es bei 14 grad kühler noch viel kühler
ist es aber hier im nordwest mit nur 12
bis 13 grad
und das liegt an den grauen regenwolken
die davon nordwesten reindrücken bei
einem bögen südwestwind freund hier ist
es hier zwischen der ostsee und dem
oberrhein da zeigt sich die sonne
tatsächlich auch mal länger am alpenrand
lassen die regenfälle allmählich nach
der pfingstsonntag bringt uns dann
freundliches wetter in süddeutschland
der pfingstmontag dann vor allen dingen
im südosten da steigen die temperaturen
bis 23 grad und damit einen schönen
abend